first guy last time had that again
I started we've like what's the amount
and then I took five percent of that
five percent of it so I could work out
how much to add okay so here what's
different is I'm decreasing and so I'm
gonna be not adding I'll be subtracting
later on okay but I still want to work
out 60 percent that's how much I will be
taking you with sir here's my I'm at
$440 to find 60 percent of it I will
multiply by 60 over 100 that's the 60
percent in there okay some of you have
noticed and told me our 68 100 that's 6
over 10 that's also 3 over 5 they're all
equivalent fractions they'll all give
you the same on top okay
so when you do that we're going to get a
number right here someone already
calculated what 60 percent yeah Daniel
the back yeah
264 exactly yeah does that check out
okay so now I've worked this out that's
like at this step so I'm trying to work
out down what's left over the answer how
am I going to use that 264 yeah
fantastic there note that - side effect
you might even like to point to it and
say there's the decrease right instead
of the sorry instead of the increase
which became a plus right so that's why
I'm taking away that 2/6
okay so someone final answer for me yeah
Courtney 176 who Greece yep excellent
fantastic okay now just before we leave
off this and you guys can have a go at
the rest how would I do this the other
way which is a bit quicker but maybe
requires a bit more thought to it here's
my clue starts off with 4:40 again but
what shall I do with her did anyone get
yeah all right let me walk you through
it pay attention carefully to how I did
it here and what I actually x right so
I'm gonna multiply again
okay and I am going to multiply by
something over a hundred that's a
percentage right but the question is
well what will I have left okay because
here it's like 100 plus a bit more gets
bigger right so here we're going to have
something less here uh-huh okay
I'm going to have 40 up here because
when you take away 60% out of a hundred
you're left with 40% there's that 40
over 100 40 percent so this is going to
land you one two steps exactly here you
can go to your calculator and you can
double check it
that'll give you a hundred and seventy
six directly okay because it's really
taking at 60 or 100 away but it's built
into that one line okay both of these
approaches are flying you have to think
a little bit more to get there but it's
quicker in terms of working all right